to be able to do a movie
off a tv show it just it baffles me and
people are like why don't you do a
smallville movie why
like no no one's ever asked and i'm old
but lex could be old
so i'm like i don't know why i do we
could do do a follow-up that'd be oh
yeah it'll be fun right i don't
but then i was like then you make
another one and you guys
there was some interview where somebody
asked you you know you said you would
keep doing it no matter what like you'd
love it just keep them coming is that
true would you
continue to do these i mean yeah i i
think in a
in a vacuum it's tough to say that but
if all of the
key elements remain in place and and
that
one of the biggest is the appetite uh
from the fans um yeah we've always sort
of said that
you know this was a gift of a job that
kind of changed all of our lives
in in wonderful ways and
you know people still want it and we
come together once every couple years
we want to see each other anyway like
it's an opportunity for like a family
reunion basically so
um and they never give us much time to
shoot these things so it's not like it
really cuts into anybody's schedule and
i think yeah i think we
i think it would be i think it'd be dope
to be part of something where you see a
character
age from you know their late 20s
to their death beds even though delay
will always look the same
like people will be able to document
that it's been you know a long time
you know it's going to be like psych 10
you know psych 10
sean loses his hair you see right you
know when yeah
the defending hairs they think hair
movie i mean that's going to be that's
going to be such a
heart-wrenching you know an all-new
special a special psych movie
you see what i'm saying but you you
would do it do like too you feel the
same way james does about it
yeah i mean i love i love the cast i
love working all the creators involved i
love the crew
we have a a wonderful time it's as wrote
they were saying it's a
it's a family reunion so i think as long
as people wanted to
to see it and that's you know and that's
the side of it that i also enjoy is
the fact that people really uh
look forward to the movies coming out
they look forward to seeing where these
characters are so i think as long as the
appetite was there for it
i would love to keep going why not yes
one of my friends
i've known him for a long time he was he
was actually my assistant in on
smallville and some
other things his name's troy and i talk
about it every once in a while but troy
said
that cat that that show
he's it's like no other show he does
tons of extra work
you might know red-headed troy oh
right yeah he said he would just show up
on set sometimes just
because everybody just had so much fun
and everybody loved that show and the
crew would just talk about it
i've never heard someone i mean look we
had a great crew people liked it it was
really hard work but like
the response that i hear is just like it
was just
they all they want to do is work on
psych they just it was the best job
ever and you felt that did you guys feel
that yeah because i think i think on our
show like
everyone was just respected we all can't
have a good time no one took themselves
too seriously i think oftentimes
especially when you get actors on
television shows they can really start
to take
themselves seriously and it has a domino
effect
it really changes the energy inside of
this you know
inside the inside the foot inside the
space really and on our shoulder and i
we
were thankful to have a job we wanted to
make sure that everyone was always
respected and appreciated and i think
that just translated throughout the uh
throughout the set so everyone anyone
came they always had a good time
but we never got we never got tripped up
by that like uh
existential sort of creative integrity
uh conversation that i think happens a
lot when a series
begins to sustain itself i mean when
when dulay's dressed up like a wizard
and
you know i s my character suddenly
doesn't know how to tell time anymore
it's tough to like it's tough to take
anything too seriously
i mean the bits that we were doing day
in and day out like they
they just lend themselves to nonsense
like we re
very rarely did we stop and like
question
any of the things that could potentially
lead to conflict
on a set